les tests antigénique sont arrivés
depuis lundi 2 novembre il est désormais
possible d'aller se faire tester en
pharmacie une nouvelle tâche confiée par
le gouvernement qui doit permettre de
désengorger les laboratoires on essaie
d'être réactif et faire ça dans des
bonnes conditions
c'est à dire qu'on fait passer n'importe
comment on a été formé pour ce geste par
une par une infirmière qui est venu deux
journées entières pour nous former aux
ponots formés aux gestes
donc on
donc on essaie de répondre présent à la
nouvelle mission qui nous est confiée
dans le but de gérer au maximum cette
crise sanitaire
ces tests se font sans rendez-vous et
gratuitement dans les pharmacies
ils ont pourtant un coût pour les
professionnels les tests sont à notre
charge le matériel au chat
heureusement le
le sens commercial à plus de mettre à
disposition un local qui nous permet de
réaliser ces tests dans de bonnes
conditions sanitaires depuis que la
pharmacie de montigny a démarré les
tests environ 10% et personnes ont été
testées positives entre 50 et 70
personnes viennent se faire dépister
chaque jour je me suis fait tester parce
que notre employeur nous demande de le
faire
moi je me suis déjà fait tester une
première fois parce que j'avais des
symptômes or c'était pas ça et là c'est
parce qu'on a plusieurs cas dans notre
équipe
c'est rassurant et puis ça évite de
perdre du temps et de s'inquiéter de
s'angoisser en 72 heures plus rapide que
les tests pcr les tests antigénique sont
pourtant basé sur le même principe un
prélèvement nasal la différence il
recherche la protéine du virus et non
pas son génome les résultats sont alors
accessibles en moins de 30 minutes